suprémaciste blanc a attaqué deux
mosquées il ya au moins 49 morts
cet homme a expliqué dans un long texte
avant l'attentât qu' il était allé en
france et qu'il y avait vu ce qu'il
appelle le grand remplacement vous savez
si cette théorie selon laquelle
l'immigration musulmane est en train de
changer le visage du pays et que c'est
pour ça qu'il avait voulu réagir
d'où la question que nous nous posons
craignez vous que ce type d'attentats
contre des mosquées contre donc des
représentations de l'islam puisse
arriver en france avant de lancer le
débat je vous livre ce tweet d'emmanuel
macron en réaction à l'attentât le
président de la république
évidemment en voit tout sait toutes ses
pensées aux victimes
et il précise que la france se dresse
contre toute forme d'extrémisme et puis
il ya un autre tweet beaucoup plus
politique beaucoup plus explicite celui
là c'est celui de ian brossât qu'est la
tête de liste du parti communiste pour
les européennes et ian brossât dit ceci
l'extrême droite eu ses idées
nauséabondes sèment la mort ne jamais
l'oublier et les combattre pied à pied
étienne girard c'est vrai que nous
n'avons pas connu en france ce type
d'attentât alors même que le terrorisme
islamiste à a été très violent et a
commis des centaines de victimes
et donc on aurait pu imaginer qu'on a eu
de ce type de réaction est ce qu'à votre
avis à un risque d'attentât contre les
musulmans d'attentats contre les
mosquées en france
oui bien sûr s'il n'y a pas eu
d'attentât contre les musulmans depuis
2015 il ya eu des tentatives
il ya eu des cellules d'ultra droite qui
ont envisagé fomenté des attentats
contre des mosquées contre des individus
radicalisés
il ya une vague d'attentats d'une vague
d'arrestations en septembre 2010 est une
autre vague d'arrestations en avril 2018
a donc si on n'en a pas eu
c'est peut-être aussi parce que nos
services de renseignement ont une
certaine efficacité mais peut-être aussi
parce que ya pas suffisamment de
personnes déterminées dans les milieux
du tra droite
s'il suffisait à qu'avec suffisamment de
moyens pour pour organiser ce genre
d'exactions donc oui il ya un risque
mais on peut constater que ça n'a pas eu
lieu
et rien ne dit que ça aurait eu
heureusement que ça aura lieu demain
vous parlez de ces mouvements d'extrême
droite violentes ont été démantelés
effectivement il ya un spécialiste de
sujets au gouvernement c'est laurent
nunez qui est secrétaire d'état auprès
du ministre de l'intérieur et qui est
l'ancien patron de la dgsi c'est à dire
la lah les services secrets intérieurs
il était d'ailleurs à la tête de la dgst
au moment où un réseau avait été
démantelé un réseau aux as et à fo et il
revenait sur ce sujet c'était en fin
d'année dernière
ces groupuscules s'entraîne s'organise
se prépare à ce qu'ils appellent le
grand soir et au travers d'entraînement
qui tourne autour du survivalisme ça
leur donne l'occasion d'entraînement
mais qui parfois sont effectués avec des
armes
et puis pour certains groupes il faut
lire ce sont même des explosifs qui ont
été testées comme bernard il ya un
risque de ce type selon vous en france
moi je crois qu'il ya un risque qui est
encore plus grand c'est le fait que
jusqu'à présent les français les
européens en rut est quand même
extrêmement patient face aux agressions
que l'islamisme ne cesse de répéter
vis-à-vis de l'occident et que le risque
c'est pas tellement qu' il y ait
quelques individus qui tentent un
attentat c'est qu'il y ait effectivement
une partie importante de la population
qui est bien décide de mettre fin je
dirais la situation et je dirais à
l'impunité en particulier je dirais des
prêcheurs islamistes partout sur le
territoire
donc je crois que beaucoup plus que
simplement quelques attentats qui ne
seraient dans le fond finalement qu'une
expression de la justice commutative une
réponse du berger à la bergère
je crois que ce qui est vraiment
dangereux c'est le délitement du lien
social et c'est le fait que
incontestablement l'islamisme
détruite je dirais de l'intérieur la
cohérence du corps social est que ce
corps social ne réagit d'une manière
extrêmement violente
mais cette fois ci de manière beaucoup
plus généralisée et pas simplement par
quelques attentats de ce type
moi ce qui me frappe justement c'est que
depuis surtout depuis 2015 et les
attentats de 2015 c'est que je pense que
cette angoisse est craintes et
appréhensions elle est dans la tête et
dans le coeur de tous c'est à dire que
après le 13 novembre particulièrement on
a tous réagi en disant ça y est
maintenant il va y avoir des gens qui
vont l'insupportable a été atteint et
les français qui sont mesurées qui
finalement ont cette capacité aussi
d'absorber les chocs d'avoir une
certaine résilience par rapport à tout
ça ça va péter et maintenance à papeete
alors il ya eu des tentatives
effectivement des jouets sûrement mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que si
vraiment il y avait eu c'est vrai
puisque je vais dire mais quand il ya
volonté on y arrive toujours donc
aujourd'hui en france les dispositifs de
sécurité et doivent être bien plus
important que ce que ce qui était le cas
en nouvelle zélande qui était censé être
un pays pacifique
enfin en tout cas au top au top 10 des
pays les plus riches foules dans le
monde donc ça voilà c'était peut-être
plus facile de s'attaquer à des mosquées
la baguette s'attaque à des mosquées à
paris moi ce qui me frappe surtout c'est
que cette violence pour l'instant lé
contenu alors est ce que c'est parce
qu'on est un pays où même si il ya des
questions sur l'immigration même si
certains estiment et surtout les plus
défavorisés dans l'est dans les
quartiers où il ya une accumulation des
nouveaux arrivants des migrants que
c'est difficile et que il ya un peu un
ras-le-bol et une saturation est ce
qu'on n'a pas aussi parce que on est
encore une fois un pays d'immigration
depuis des décennies la capacité
d'absorber tout ça et je suis pas en
train de dire que c'est normal qu'on
absorbe et que du coup on va toujours
l'absorber mais en tout cas une chose me
frappe c'est que notre pays
qui est montré du doigt par les
islamistes à cause de son principe
républicain de son principe laïc
en attendant ça n'a pas versé pour
l'instant dans le règlement de comptes
les pays où il ya eu des attentes a cédé
pays de type anglo saxons de type plutot
communautariste à la nouvelle zélande le
royaume uni en 2017
il ya eu aussi le canal au québec
amérique a été atteint c'est des
sociétés où les modèles sont pas tout à
fait des modèles républicains comme l'on
peut lire en france et dans ces pays-là
sap est donc moi je trouve c'est bien de
s'interroger aussi sur sur ce qui fait
aujourd'hui que le lien même s'il est
très distendue ici ça se complique
tiens tiens encore c'est peut-être voilà
peut-être un miracle peut-être que c'est
pas pour longtemps
en tout cas pour l'instant ça tient
c'est vrai j'ai qu'ils débloquent eux
s'attendaient pas à qui ce type
d'attentât forcément en nouvelle zélande
parce que culturellement ou c'est un
pays qui n'est pas un pays de 2
d'immigration musulmane massive je crois
qu'il ya beaucoup moins de d'immigrés
musulmans là bas que qu'en france par
exemple est pourtant cet aspect là a été
bien soulignée par par le par le
terroriste alors c'est simple et c'est
marrant parce que c'est un pays qui est
assez permissif en matière de détention
des armes à feu c'est un espèce de petit
états unis parce qu'il ya eu cinq ou six
millions de personnes en nouvelle
zélande mais par rapport à cet aspect là
faut jamais oublier que c'est un c'est
un acte de terrorisme et l'acte de
terrorisme avant de tuer il a une
vocation première
dans sa définition c'est ça ce qu'on
appelle sa medi activité là je parle
avec avec des spécialistes à dire que la
première victime
c'est avant tout les millions de
personnes qui sont derrière leur poste
de télé derrière leur poste de radio
derrière leur écran d'ordinateur et
toute la folie du monde qui se retrouve
beaucoup dans les oppositions
communautaire en ce moment et bien elle
a pour outil principal le terrorisme
avant tout pour opposer des communautés
et vous disiez est ce que ça peut
arriver en france pourquoi je dis ça et
bien ça arrive beaucoup plus souvent
dans les pays musulmans
les actes de terrorisme les plus
violents à l'endroit des mosquées ces
dernières années
ils ont eu lieu dans des pays musulmans
où l'état islamique de confession
sunnite aux salafistes s'est opposé à
des religieux chiites exemple bir el
abed en egypte plus de 300 morts
koweit une cinquantaine de morts
l'ensemble des grands attentats contre
les mosquées ces dernières années ont eu
lieu par des musulmans contre d'autres
formes musulmane d'eau que je ne
résoudrai pas cet acte terrorisme à une
organisation religieuse contre une autre
ou des pays occidentaux contre contre
des formes communautaires mais plutôt
des espèces de de folie qui s'exprime un
peu partout et qui utilise le terrorisme
pour vraiment violente et l'ensemble des
populations les retranchés dans leur for
intérieur et provoquer la terreur par
l'intermédiaire de l'outil médiatique et
nous en sommes à ces éléments avant tout
ça que j'aimerais bien mettre en
perspective si vous me le permettez
certainement été jerada peut-être aussi
une hypothèse ne suis pas du tout sûr
que je vous la livre tel quel en france
on peut parler on peut tenir un discours
offensif voire critiques contre l'islam
il ya des partis politiques ils vont le
rassemblement national il ya des
romanciers ont passé michel houellebecq
à l'instant et peut-être que justement
parce que la parole est libre et bien ça
permet de te faire que ces questions de
2,2 parfois d'opposition entre les
communautés ou contre les religions mais
ça se passe comme ça doit se passer
c'est à dire dans le champ démocratique
et pas par la violence
j'aimerais est totalement d'accord avec
vous mais vous savez il suffit d'un
individu extrêmement déterminé
en norvège anders breivik à lui tout
seul il a réussi a tué 69 personnes
quand même donc on peut en effet gloser
sur la résilience du modèle français on
a raison pour l'instant il suffit quand
même d'une seule personne d'un petit
groupe ultra déterminé qui arrive et on
aura un jour ce genre d'hypothèse sera
sera totalement battu en brèche
donc l'enjeu c'est évidemment notre
modèle que notre démocratie conserve ses
principes que notre modèle républicain
conserve ses principes ça peut aider
puisqu'il peut aussi aider ces les
services de renseignement en effet je
pense qu'il ya un vrai sujet en
nouvelle-zélande il s'y attendait pas du
tout en france maintenant depuis 2015 on
s'y attend on a même un directeur de la
dgfip a expliqué qu'il y avait un risque
de à l'apathie guerre civile mais tout
le monde a compris guerre civile avec
deux confrontations entre l'extrême
droite et le monde musulman
donc on a des officiers du renseignement
qui surveille ça de façon extrêmement
précise ça aide beaucoup je pense je
laisse le dernier mot si vous le voulez
bien un internaute babineau qui nous dit
la montée de la haine islamophobe en
france explosent depuis ces dernières
années
ce n'est pas normal on passe à un autre
sujet au moins dramatique que
heureusement c'est celui des prochaines
élections européennes vous savez que la
république en marche n'a toujours pas de
tête de liste le parti socialiste a
expliqué qu'elle recherchait pas
forcément parce que ça se passe pas très
bien pour eux en ce moment et ils ont
peut-être trouvé leur sauveur en la
personne de raphaël glucksmann qui est
essayiste engagé à gauche et qui est
tête de liste
une liste de rassemblement de la gauche
qui pourrait recevoir
le soutien du parti socialiste est même
quasiment officiel si vous ne le
connaissez